am anfang war der zufall der urknall
formte das universum der zufall hat
etwas archaisches ein relikt aus einer
fernen zeit der der mensch der natur
noch ausgeliefert war
heute können wir auf ihn verzichten
diesen launischen spielverderber oder
etwa doch nicht
es gibt leute die halten den zufall für
eine unschätzbare kraft wie der
erfolgreiche deutsche wissenschaftsautor
stefan klein ist dass das
unvorhergesehene und das unvorhersehbare
den menschen angst macht
wie beruhigend google schaltet für uns
den zufall aus seine algorithmen kennen
unser suchverhalten begrenzen damit aber
unsere sicht auf die welt
der mensch ist eine latente fehlerquelle
nun soll der computer ihm selbst
fahrenden auto ans steuer und beim
reisen lassen wir den zufall gern daheim
vergleichen unendlich angebote lesen
empfehlungen alles um böse
überraschungen zu vermeiden wenn sie den
zufall völlig aus ihrem leben
ausschalten dann schalten sie zu viele
möglichkeiten aus ihrem leben aus dann
ist ihr leben viel enger als es sein
müsste
anger die werbung verspricht er das
gegenteil so viele potenzielle partner
wie nie zuvor
auslese per wegwischen und dundee
perfect match die vollkommene
übereinstimmung schöne neue dating bett
meine partnersuche über das ich nicht
hin zu fall
jeder mensch verliebt sich durch zufall
sie können nicht voraussehen wen sie
treffen werden
das sind zufällige was schwein ist was
dann alles möglich ist zeigt der
aktuelle film men ab wenn zwei sich
finden dass sie eigentlich gar nicht
gemeint war
das ist interessant nicht also einen
film in dem alles vorhersehbar ist den
würde sich kein mensch ansehen wollen
aber in ihrem leben da erwarten sie dass
das alles nach schnürchen abläuft
durch zufälle lernen wir wenn zufällig
etwas geschieht dann werden wir wach
dann werden wir bereit zu lernen und
dabei wird ein bestimmter
neurotransmitter das ist also ein hormon
im gehirn ausgeschüttet das dopamin und
das bringt uns in der tat in ein
leichter raus stimmung finden ohne zu
suchen
selbst die seriöse forschung liegt davon
wären die ptc heißt das zauberwort
nach einer persischen geschichte der
drei prinzen von serien die auf umwegen
große entdeckung machten ein modernes
zufallsprodukt ist etwa die potenzpille
viagra
ursprünglich entwickelt als herz
kreislauf mittel auch künstler vertrauen
auf den zufall als partner jackson
pollock begründete mit seinen beliebigen
spritzern auf der leinwand gar eine neue
kunstrichtung das action painting
und der schweizer großmeister der etb
art daniel spoerri erhob die willkür des
moments zum eigentlichen gestalter darum
dass sich beweisen wollte dass der
zufall genau so schön in
anführungsstrichen wie das bewusst von
einem von einem einzelnen vor allem
individuum gestaltete ist es geht nur
darum dass wir erstens mit einer
gewissen gelassenheit durch das leben
gehen und akzeptieren das ist
unvorhersehbares gibt anerkennen dass
wir die kraft haben mit diesem
unvorhersehbaren umzugehen und uns
schließlich darüber freuen dass es
dieses unvorhersehbare gibt weil nur so
können wir lernen
lassen wir den zufall also ruhig öfter
seine schöpferische arbeit tun denn
gemäss wahrscheinlichkeit folgt auf jede
böse überraschung irgendwann sicher eine
gute